an army of volunteers has been helping
with rescues in texas the driver of a
monster truck rescued storm victims zub
farrell used his huge rig to drive deep
into flood waters to shuttle stranded
residents to safety michelle miller is
in houston with more michelle good
morning
good morning all across houston you have
neighborhoods that look like this you
can see the water line it's up to my
neck obviously
residents could get back in to start the
cleanup but there were towns that were
virtual islands folks could not get out
that's where we met up with fema as they
organized the next stage of their search
and rescue as their operations went from
house to house
specialty forces are loading in supplies
to reach a stranded wharton texas this
is a staging ground 400 members strong
of specialty rescue teams from all over
the map from new jersey california
arizona alabama tennessee
these are the folks going in
and pulling people out
tennessee's urban rescue task force took
military high water trucks across a
flooded roadway
we joined them as they walked door to
door residents here were cut off for
three days
the first that we really
have been able to talk to i know we have
been waiting on
the red cross from but they have not
made it right
they're using regular maps
four take texas
but also leaving digital breadcrumbs
with this device
a code determines what they found if we
come across anybody that's in a house
we'll mark it as a shelter in place if
there's 10 people in there we'll mark it
10 times are you here by yourself but
people aren't the only targets
california's task force one was out on
the water rescuing animals in the town
wading through high water they also
checked each house for any sign of life
back at the staging ground the little
ones got a bath a new life after being
left for day this city
is like it was like an island when we
showed up it was about four feet deeper
when we showed up yesterday
the center of it was dry
everything around it was about six to
eight feet of water
keen black is in charge of distributing
each of these task forces around wharton
in just a few days they saved a
community mostly yesterday we pulled out
about 75 people a lot of pets actually
evacuated a complete nursing home with
every street now highlighted it's on to
the next town
mission accomplished yes
[Music]
and those specialty teams are on their
ninth straight day anthony we should
note that while some will remain in the
houston area others are being deployed
south of here to areas newly hit by
flooding and east to beaumont texas
michelle miller in houston those folks
are doing amazing work michelle thank
you